citizens of the reject Nation we are
back for another DC Animated Universe
film in universe as John and I are
watching for the very first time the
death of Super Bowl are you ready for
the death never no one can never two in
one year koi first caval now this what
emotionally devastating did you know
this comic series when it came out was
it because it was pretty pop culturally
landmarky I know the story of this I
know broad strokes but I don't remember
that I'm hoping for a good voice cast
for cyborg for Superboy I got a lot of
love for steel very curious how they
handle those characters if they're in
fact part of this please do leave a
comment below let us know which of these
you've enjoyed what you want us to watch
next tell us we got for lunch we're
ready for it also hit that like hit that
notification Bell hit lots of buttons in
various places and share this with your
friends because the only way we get to
keep doing these is by knowing you guys
are enjoying them and you seem to base
we're gonna keep doing them and remember
if you want to watch all of this
beginning to end without pause check out
the patreon where you can watch it and
sync it up with us live using your HBO
Max maybe use your Blu-rays your respect
physical media and with that sync up you
get the experience of
our resting faces
for this week's episode we're gonna take
a week off because I'm traveling but
when I'm back we're gonna dive into the
next thing again like subscribe comment
and no matter what enjoy us enjoying
hopefully the death of Superman
a little bit of an optimistic opening
for you sir right before that and ironic
because it's gonna end darkish so I like
that yeah a little dichotomy well
immediately awry but here we go
serve with the tech weapons last week
makes a nostalgic for assault rifles how
many of these start with driving a lot I
feel like they're always driving but
this one's got inter gang
what a stash
these are all Dodge Charger police cars
no more Dead Cops no more Dead Cops step
away from the mayor Mannheim don't give
me a reason then you shouldn't have
given me one hey
come on fella you don't want to be a cop
killer yeah why is that look at that
this guy is Wrecking [__] I don't think
he cares about it yeah I don't feel like
he's got a lot of morals
hey ever wonder what it feels like to
fall from a great distance
let's find out oh
whoa looks like it hurts be right back
[Music]
work damn
It crap it's a transport me on my
command boom troops not Bowman
you're supposed to exposition
I'm gonna punch this alien technology
Manheim he's got three squares a day and
light Saturday
oh
dropless is clean again
should know by now Manheim no one tears
my city apart and gets away with it just
watch Once I want to see Superman tear
like all their clothes off no so sorry
like
I wasn't wearing anything under the
Mexican my modesty
not to make light of the you know very
gripping title card
owski who is the unluckiest sailor in
town
I'm a restaurant tour Acer clubs Bar and
Grill
how about a picture for the joint well
surf and turf
yeah
stupid thing never works when you need
it to I got you covered Jimmy Olsen
you're a lifesaver Jimmy yeah I'll make
sure to get this to you Mr babowski see
you down at the Joint kid see an
important Easter egg a little bit as he
is in the comics I like the Sailor it
always get some bad High drinks
accidentally oh oh available I have to
be somewhere I think you could help with
the cleanup ah again
what the hell have you been up against
an inter-gang crew that somehow got a
hold of a mother box
disarm is from apocalypse too we need to
get this analyzed maybe one of the
others could help we need my dad I could
take it to him if you want oh nah it's
cool no problem ever got better by
avoiding it well at least I won't be
slowing you down on cleanup
me about 30.
I wonder if it's too late to join the
Titans
is there an age limit
go for it dude I would I'll be all for
it more funny flash you and Nightwing
and all that and here's the compartment
that contain me as an infant I've only
gotten so far studying Kryptonian
technology that's why I handed the job
over to Dr Clyburn and her crew oh only
recently have we discovered these super
condensed ionized crystals we believe
they acted as hyperwave acceleration
units for transport the gas to put it
simply
English please for us it can only be
activated one way
oh
whoa my sole purpose on this journey is
to inform you assist you and protect you
and all Kryptonian life and you're
looking at the last son of krypton's
Nanny
super Nan there's your headline Miss
Lane and like you and the rest of the
world to meet my parents
this is all moving so fast we just met
there's a really smart woman I know who
always says daylight is the best
disinfectant lift back to the planet and
save me from expensing cab fare to Perry
white you are heroic yeah that's why
Perry doesn't smear him is because he
saves him all this Fair big expenses
frankly tropolis seems like a lot of
traffic everyone's always driving in the
openings
seriously oh
[Music]
I want to be flown around town
swell look at how happy you asked for a
happy intro just remember I did I did
because it's despair to come get
punished for this you had that interview
with your super friend I know what that
means
what in here
oh the lane cave
oh
oh where I'm on our trip to the Hamptons
this weekend uh about that
I gave up that interview with the
Secretary of State I can explain you
mean it's not some secret meeting with
some secret spies and some secret
location my parents are in town
I don't want me to meet them don't you
think it's time no you're right you
should meet them it's just that this is
unchartered territory for me and there's
some things I need to get used to
sharing oh it's your parents what am I
gonna find out that you were a huge dork
I already know that
oh and I asked for romance and now I
feel like I'm gonna be punished for that
oh definitely this is just such a stack
in the deck it's a sweet scene Dr irons
is one of Starlight there he is
oh
yeah it's him
have we met at a construction site once
you did okay they did tied in yeah it's
definitely from apocalypse but it's been
bonded with earth-based triformulize at
an atomic level
that means it's even stronger than you
Victor I always got an encouraging word
it sure didn't come from here maybe
Wayne Tech or even of course cyborg
we'll catch up later
oh let's I appreciate you bringing me in
on this son it's been a long time yeah I
know sorry about that get lunch fixing
things
those weapons this morning they're based
on alien technology but clearly modified
for intergang here on Earth but as you
can see I spend my days under house
arrest I've added a little dash of
kryptonite green
that's Stephen Colbert that'd be amazing
intergang is connections all over the
planet you know something I don't know
only that this City's never going to
love you just for hating me
[Music]
that's a bar so you're meeting the
parents oh God make it stop
I had a suspicion something was up when
you stopped calling him Smallville oh
meanwhile in an anime
[Laughter]
she hadn't casually caught that I would
have wandered into space and she clearly
needs it very expensive to get Machinery
up there just twirling wrenches around
space grade wrench all right
[Music]
caliber come in Houston I don't remember
that Hank Henshaw story starting in
space I'm intrigued I'm just looking for
a red cape you can see it if he's above
the exosphere he's been up here twice
you know shaved my ass one time oh cool
yes sir you can always count on Superman
oh boy famous last words
his voice sounded familiar too yeah I
couldn't quite place it
hated to interrupt your plans how was
your night in the town Mr Luthor
[Music]
Happy Leif Ericson day
they could take good durians do you have
something for me sometimes I forget
which one of us the government is placed
under house arrest
we've got unidentified debris heading
our way everyone back to the ship always
happy to walk among the greatest minds
of this generation that's why I bought
them
in spite of my false conviction at the
hands of these Vigilantes lexcorp has
stayed on Mission redoubling its efforts
to find the next alien ubermensch and
crush it in its infancy ubermench show
me what you found what a disrupter in
the Houston's encrypted feed from the
Excalibur shuttle and something's
heading our way
huh
what they're running away from we have a
satellite nearby can we pull up Google
Earth enhance
enlarge
oh no we're not going to make it like
hell we're not Superman will save us
oh no oh no
he's Superman
oh
oh Jesus oh no this is heartbreaking no
[Music]
so like 50s kid about it and then it was
his own death oh there he is
oh no
your son's anti-toxin will be delivered
within the hour
congratulations on his survival
pleasure doing business with you
oh interesting
seriously Diana we need to use code
names in the field you just called me
Diana but that's what you want to be
called
[Music]
you want to be called Superman
pretty sure it's cheating even if it's a
secret identity and both parties don't
know
they're new at this
okay
polyamory's cool with conversation
whoa
he gave it to me
oh
you mean Lois yeah funny how you use her
actual name but don't allow her to know
yours well I mean
it's a complicated relationship kind of
like ours was it was nice for a while
sending now past nine thousand meters
it's over nine thousand
it almost looks like a capsule Corp too
dive deeper I want to find that
meteorite
you come down here yeah instead of
sending James Cameron the worst Think
Tank ever there's someone out there
let's do this the trench oh what could
have been those are atlanteans you idiot
hold on Lex
up something
[Music]
someone's watching Star Wars
Aquaman loves it
thank you
oh
damn that's how you get sharks Very
Metal
sounds like you're being torn apart Mr
Luthor are you still there
we need to go deeper oh
what the hell
whoa dammits no
[Music]
intriguing this creature let's see how
this plays out
it's traveled light years through space
and survived a catastrophic entry to
Earth the Blue Boy Scout could have some
competition and I'm recruiting
the operating budget for the upcoming
fiscal year utilities are above what the
U.N cleared for funding guys I'll handle
it
what else
just the Excalibur incident only three
bodies recovered I've got my guards
investigating the impact area we'll meet
next Thursday same bad time same bad
Channel
I have a meeting with the Headmaster at
Damien's boarding school no way Batman
as a parent-teacher conference that's
great are you in the PTA too
I'm Batman we need more chaperones for
homecoming
I'm just joking I think that's great
[Laughter]
[Music]
we could just push the meeting back to
that evening can't I've got rehearsal
dinner that night is he in a play
yes he's getting married somehow yep
married the next day limos Banquet Hall
DJ the hall shebang just immediate
family you understand
does she know about you are you kidding
I told her ages ago geez you can't drop
a bomb like that on the honeymoon oh
dude uh oh aren't you worried about
bringing her into your world the dangers
the sacrifice interest Clark that's what
marriage is all about I mean yeah her
life's always going to be at risk the
kid was a daredevil this clerk the guy
who irons his socks sounds like there's
a lot I don't know warn me now if I
should keep my distance well you
wouldn't be the first young lady to
break his heart
TMI ma oh
first there was Lena lovely girl lived
next door then there was the girl on the
swim team Laurel Laura
um Lori lamaris I remember her he likes
LLC
he went through a big yellow Cool J
phase as well had to make sure some
things couldn't wait to get me out of
there could you well that's not true I
didn't want you to be bored by all those
stories this is the first time I think
I've ever learned anything about you to
be honest it drove home how much
distance you keep between us sure
there's something else going on and
sometimes I feel like it scares you that
I might get to the truth you have no
idea how can I show my psychology you
know in a more obvious way
Amber Heard yep there she is this uh
certain audience is very thrilled
Carousel strides the Behemoth I don't
see any sign of it
I need to get back to the others you see
a trail of tracks
he's gotta get back to the apps no sign
no sign at all not a literal sign but no
sign I couldn't follow this could not
look 20 feet that way you deserve
someone special we raised you so the you
could be yourself
we didn't raise you to be alone honey
oh
yeah
cocaine bear
[Laughter]
never did only food out guys or cocaine
yeah it's like a fully set table right
there this is your first time camping
yes they're from Metropolis
laughs
oh
oh yep oh wow
oh Brian's to oh
oh Brian is toast yes yeah
oh no
I'm crushing your head
Predator just seeking out things to
destroy we need to talk
okay I can eat around 2PM right whatever
works for you works for me there's a
place in Hobbs Bay oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh
Flash and a few others are already
headed out Arthur spotted something
offshore might be related I've got a
lunch with Lois but I'll cancel uh this
lunch wouldn't have anything to do with
what we were discussing the other day
call if the league needs me is that your
way of saying mind your own business
yep it's my way of saying I really want
to avoid these life events and then
please call me if you the league needs
me
[Applause]
pick up the spare pick up that spare
it killed him oh Reckless firing into
the crowd success us blowing up that gas
station kills me
commentary
if anyone's watching this send help this
Monster's killing everyone
streaming from a blackberries bold no no
get out of there
everything
[Music]
I've been getting to do something that's
right 20 movies in
no
no he had a good quiet run
wow
Hawk's still alive Lantern we need a
perimeter like hell this is no time for
a rope-a-dope I'm a member of the Green
Lantern Corps
we eat monsters like this for breakfast
ugh famous last words
oh
didn't see that coming
yes oh
oh
good peace
the waves
fast enough to see the flash
nice do three Leaguers down and we only
just got here need backup now
three Leaguers are beleaguered good
thing I'm this rich guy in a bat suit
I'll fight
hard-earned money being spent Lex
Dr Robotnik
I expect to have more obedience samples
soon very soon I don't want samples I
want an army want paraduct
now that creature you told me about
we're tracking it down Dabney let me
just twirl my mustache for real not Pure
Evil
oh
damn
follow you bastard
I see bad sweat a little bit yeah I'm
always rooting for him but you know
brings his Personality yeah
counter punch counter punch
and that's pretty much how I helped him
save the city more or less
my man what did you want to talk about
there's a reason why I'm so secretive
and I think you deserve to know why
and
[Music]
I'm Superman
oh that's
oh that's good Clark
look at me look at me
oh my God
you always showed up around the same
time it was like you were just there oh
my God this is so unethical you wrote
stories about yourself
are those people even your parents
they are but you know it's complicated
oh my God you're from another planet
say it louder
I did this so that they wouldn't have to
pay for my choices
you want me to live with it too
I hope you can because there's something
else I've been keeping secret I'm
pregnant
Jimmy I'm busy call back a monster's
heading towards Metropolis he's already
taken out half the Justice League
he must have heard
my last Secret
oh the suit up moment oh here we go
there it is yes
oh
that's not a secret Clark oh you're
precious baby boy
can you tell what he's thinking all
about the fight the killing machine damn
come on Jeremy Johns you can do this
what another gas station there's a lot
of everybody's driving all the time the
Dewey Cox the sink of this movie as gas
stations oh no
char-broiled Manhunter
damn wow
do you bleed I do I help I don't like it
it's not looking too good cyborg
we can take this creep come on let's no
where is that monstrosity heading toward
Metropolis
we need you Clark oh
I call you out monster yes
challenged you to a dance battle
oh
no
not her hair ties
[Music]
damn
but my hero you will fall
thank you
oh no nice
oh no painful no
I'm surprised there's any Diana left
after that yeah she wasn't an Amazonian
[Music]
good timing
take him down Clark
or he'll kill everyone
oh
no Rosario I don't know what hole you
crawled out of but I'm sending you back
oh damn whoa that was sick
oh super blood do you believe he ain't
got a place to go you can stay with me
while Superman cleans this Clown's clock
oh
it's the opposite of closing time just
like my buddy soups is always there for
us
I love that guy it is great it seems its
only function is destruction perhaps
it's a weapon you think what if the
Caped Wonder can't bring him down
Metropolis will still need to be
protected
I got a gun for that I can't take down
Superman but I can take down the thing
that takes time I don't know about that
Lex
oh
oh geez
damn
it's like a Shazam 2 moment was my
little David Sandberg
and various comments oh that was cool
yeah I like the flying low
oh no
we have a Hulk
wow wow
Carnage
handheldness of this yeah it's brutal
[Music]
uh no bueno hearing a Superman crowd and
pain man
oh nice so cool
yeah I love the way they're realizing
the flight
oh yep yep yep yep
my high score
these cost a lot of money now
get back to your mom son
everything's going to be okay
you save the game
kid was about to be real mad
[Music]
oh jeez let's throw a whole boat at him
better not be Bubba Bowie's boat we love
him or whatever his name is Bobby
Bazinga oh the hair pulled
I felt that soup
oh geez
not the flat iron
oh jeez
wow nice nice locked off POV yeah that
was a cool Choice you've got me
but who's got you
need to call in the cavalry
I am the Cavalry oh agent Melinda May is
the cavalry
I have to get back to work oh
yeah oh Windham
swing mad about it damn yeah punch him
out into space
yeah
oh boy oh
all the way through the atmosphere
oh Jesus
whoa
damn
Olsen keep the camera rolling
[Laughter]
you don't want to get this of course
Mako found footage movie out of this
Metroplex is and always has been under
the protection
yeah yeah put that on the T-shirt
now to get a piece of you oh
stay away from me
that's your problem boy I'm on house
arrest
no
[Music]
this guy
[Applause]
oh no
damn
[Music]
jeez man really is relentless
with the cape ah
hey
oh
you're too good for us Lois and I love
you
[Music]
I'm going Super Saiyan yep
rip his head off
or Exorcist twists I'll take it oh
all right
oh
[Music]
it's all
I ever wanted
[Music]
no
what a lucky man
I was
you cry
oh bats
ah yes the image
keep that picture forever
yeah like a Clint Eastwood costume yes
he was a hero to Metropolis but more
importantly he was a friend really sorry
sir I need you to step back a bit the
what
in many ways I'm sure they feel the loss
of their leader and comrade most of all
that's right are they gonna have to do a
separate clerk funeral or they can be
right by the casket like cheese
and yeah
oh Damien and let us not forget the
quick action from Lex Luthor who allowed
Superman the time he needed to save us
all Lex Luthor he's in the Justice
League now
unfortunately he was under house arrest
at the time so we're going to take him
into custody and add to his sentence he
would be surprised all the times he came
to visit the wisdom he would impart I
will miss those late night Chats on my
balcony
Charming oh
for Superman
always in our hearts wow
laughs
make a monument
eagerly what are you doing here that's
the DCU you got to bring it all together
holy Mary Mother of God
pray for us sinners
oh and at the hour of our death Mars
Martian Manhunter
nope nope nope nope
I don't trust this at all it always goes
well nope
Lex Corp just needs to get the payload
rocket ready so the government can get
this creature off Planet before it lands
in the wrong hands you know I've been
exonerated yes
as far as I'm concerned Cadmus is a
genetic pirate ship posing is a research
uh-oh
[Music]
where's it going
up up and away
I'm popping away whip
Shazam
Clark will show up
he's got the best reason of all to
return OH police scanners come on jeremi
midnight mood to chase the story right
now you will be trust me you drive
Jimmy's always just like in a hurry I'm
sorry
we're not driving right now we're gonna
be driving some travels
oh Jesus rose on the third day
oh
oh neither two directors for that one we
got two guys got a lot going on damn
okay
that's gotta be some ship Juju no
so do you know
I don't know much you know the next the
next Arc no I was wondering the whole
time where they'd end it because I wrote
the story and I was like
but there's like four years to tell and
like all the next thing all I really
know is is what our Lord and savior Zack
Snyder
in his films you'll notice the reckon
Wilson was Lexi okay and Rebecca Romaine
was Lois Lane okay not bad
you'll notice a lack of Zod in this take
um but still a neck snap I think uh it's
still a neck snap uh I think you'll be
very excited particularly by the next
Arc oh good is it all just Solomon
Grundy
it's just
oh that's right his experiment
it all ties together it ties into a
certain character you like I won't say
which one won't say if he was born on a
Monday or not but uh I mean that costume
they're not gonna look kind of like dead
Wing but there's uh there's a lot of
there's a lot of things that you'll go
oh right the 90s and uh there's a lot of
there's a lot of things I assume that's
what we'll match next I'm excited I grew
up in the 90s koi I'm still a 90s kid
after a break break uh I will be I'm
going on a trip but when I get back
we'll be actually it's fun to have
episode Cliff whoa
foreign
[Music]
well I mean I've seen different versions
of Steel becoming steel but you know
I'll wait to see how this one is a
certain continuity that I enjoy oh one
of my favorite characters is uh
one of my favorite characters is the
next Arc and I'm very cautious about how
they handle it because one of the things
I was really struggling with this film
is that they were trying to blend the
new 52 takes with the classics okay like
they immediately had to make Superman
more likable and they also immediately
had to make the lowest relationship they
immediately had all this stuff and I was
like because they've been doing this
like whatever this continuity's been uh
which has worked for like the individual
stories
oh a new Fortress
Wowie
as Mysteries are afoot oh man this is
like a the gift that keeps on giving
this whole postcard I love that doing
post-credit scenes with certain
characters because when you when you
know who they are it's gonna be exciting
but in the comics they teased it just
like this in the comics that was like
images that would come out you wouldn't
know what it was and now in the
hindsight it's really cool because like
I know but the audience wouldn't
necessarily okay what the mystery is but
uh yeah the combining of continuities
was a little tricky yeah I think they
handled it as best they could uh yeah so
you having read this Arc I I've the 90s
one is so powerful because you love
these characters so much and because of
the relationship with Lois oh more this
is oh
no
[Music]
they turned to Superman
yeah what
I love that you don't know I'm so
excited that you don't know because
everyone knows this image everybody
knows doomsday but like what comes next
Cyberman
cyber soup I I feel like I almost know
this character this this iteration's
name and I can't draw it to mine because
right I'm thinking about right now is
Bizarro and that's not who that is no no
obviously oh it looks like it is next
look there's a certain image there so uh
my experience was the 90s was yeah
Lois and Clark are so impactful and you
have to be attached to Jimmy and Lois
and and so many supporting his
characters that throwing it into this
universe and going like the Wonder Woman
broke up like all of it felt very like
the things look anymore he's been a dick
but he's less of a dick now you really
like him and and like there's just so
many moments that felt like remember
these called the times he's got to be
like he's gonna die because
[Music]
they're gonna
because
guys they should be together a while and
there's another character that they're
about to introduce that is one of the
most 90s characters of all time and by
the costume redesign I'm already like oh
no they're gonna [__] it up oh no oh I'm
so excited that's a that's an issue for
me as I'm like the character redesigned
just by the costume Choice I'm concerned
good but uh they did some fun nods like
the um the beard and wig on Luther is a
tie into the like a 90 storyline which
was cool they did they did a few little
little Easter eggs for us like 90s kids
but um like my man
us
but but Ben bendelson is uh I loved him
he's great and he's in the comments and
he's kind of your eyeline he's your
anchor which is something they did
really well yeah uh what did you think
having known nothing having no not much
oh yeah you some because the pop culture
relevance yeah and I mean obviously you
watch this and you're like oh okay so
this has been borrowed from many a time
in different ways or at least pieces of
it have been lifted I mean the Snyder
films seem to certainly have used parts
of this
um yeah I mean I enjoyed this into in in
part
I am torn because part of me is like man
I would have loved to have seen this
relationship build up over time and if
I'm not mistaken continuity this is the
continuity where like he's been with
Diana in the past and the lowest thing
is like more of a recent development
right in this movie it seemed like yeah
and so I thought I thought they were
cheating
yeah like yeah it was one of those
experiences that did make me wonder I
guess I I split these into three tiers
there are some of these I watch where
having not all of the context I'm like
this worked for me like Injustice was
one where people had various issues and
I was like I couldn't tell because and
that was so funny because I'd read some
of it so I knew the tone but I didn't
read far enough that I was bothered by
the apparently the changes yeah which
was very interesting I agree and this
being such an iconic story and yeah
hearing things about it over the years
and seeing pieces uh uh uh you know
adapted this is one that kind of falls
in the Middle where I was sitting there
going I wonder how this is working as an
adaptation like I am kind of aware of
the idea that this might not be like the
completely crisp definitive version of
this however uh it didn't go so far to
the opposite side of of like oh you know
like they really needed like I would
have taken more time just
I mean certainly I think it would have
been more rewarding to build the
Superman and lowest relationship over
time so that you already love them like
I thought this managed to make some
really nice moments and me sitting here
going like I want a new superhero
romance in one of these yeah that isn't
like and when I say that I don't mean
like take us back to a time where every
movie requisitely just needed a romantic
subplot that we don't really want to do
yeah like no like a True Romance that I
can fall in love with and then root for
the stakes of and and like this gave me
some of that like I I was endeared to
that I was endeared to Clark's parents I
was I was pleasantly surprised that so
much of this was kind of about
focusing in on his struggle with sharing
his life with Lois and really opening up
the full breadth of what that means
while all this Justice League stuff is
going down and them being like no no go
do your thing man we we support you we
want you to find love flash is getting
married you know yeah and uh and him you
know trying to you know then you can see
the sort of Peter parkeriness of when
they set up lunch and he's like I'm
gonna go [__] fight doomsday now
um so yeah like it's kind of in the
middle in that uh it didn't feel
obviously like a lacking adaptation but
it didn't necessarily seem like I just
saw like Flashpoint I'm sure is like way
more wacky and Broad in the country that
makes sense more to cram and that movie
didn't make me think about that concept
at all I was just dazzled the whole time
where is whereas this was like I bet
this is an adaptation I don't know if
it's like the definitive adaptation yeah
I'm now curious because we've got it
looks like reign of Superman before it's
got a movie called Superman Doomsday
which I have no idea if that's in or out
of continuity is that another adaptation
is that yeah like because we just saw
Superman Doomsday actually reign of the
Superman comes after Constantine's city
of the Demons that's exciting we get a
little trip down a little uh Constantine
day that's accepted to the house of
mystery before we go back to this uh I I
really enjoyed it and we're gonna be
taking just a week for a glue back soon
thereafter so it'll be a couple weeks
till this one but you gotta go make I
gotta go Coronas yeah I gotta go I gotta
go suspense family
um but I do think they did what the best
they could with what they had like with
the universe they built up to and all
those things and something you speak you
spoke to a second ago uh about like
romance in these movies it is starting
to bug me
in regular life that the biggest movies
in the world are often weirdly sexless
and in that mean like I don't need to
see people boning but like there's no
romance Beyond like it fitting a meat
cute like there's no like when the world
freaked out that Eternal said a sex
scene that was literally someone's
clavicles like when you saw someone like
there are deeper backless dresses like
that movie is very like wonderful dress
and Wonder Woman is a deeper yeah it's
like not even PG-13 is PG like they're
so when the world freaked out that
Marvel did that it really like opened my
eyes to the fact that the biggest movies
in the world Marvel DC
Etc are weirdly like
sexless like and I'm not saying it needs
to be you know but like it does bother
me we're not having romance in movies
we're not having love and affection
shown we're cool with violence but like
the The Death of Superman meant so much
to me as a kid because the lowest
Superman relationship had already meant
so much like I was a big 90s comic kid I
loved how Lois and Clark were I loved
what this was and the only reason this
lands isn't because of just this Justice
League loving him or just Jimmy losing a
friend it was Lois was the anchor and
then the rest was like oh I'm really
affected and so I don't know if in the
current superhero climate there is
anything akin to that because we're not
letting romance be a part of it the
closest is maybe Guardians and like that
was still a very like meat cute type of
love and like maybe the next closest to
me would be Deadpool and uh and Vanessa
but they fridged her and and and they
did the thing we're like we're gonna
make a joke about it which makes it okay
I know he's still fridge like they
didn't let it lamp shading on top of the
fridge literally you're just adding a
creature put magnets on the fridge yeah
um so I I do think there is an issue
with these movies that people are raised
on not showing that love is a strength
and this is a story that showed that
love is the thing that's worth dying for
yeah I love that Lois steps up and just
throws the rock like At first I was like
is there gonna be some kid is it gonna
be the game boy kid but no it's it's
Lois and that's like a great little full
circle moment and yeah it's like I feel
like there was a time
and and I think this is only the case
because there have been so many like you
know like requisite romantic subplots
where it's like it became almost a
progressive choice to be like there's no
love story forced into this we don't
need to do that at all and there was a
moment where I was like cool but I think
we're past that now we're done we're now
it's like we're so far in the other
direction where it's like we I want my
heart stirred a little bit and there's
like love moments like there's uh you
know I'm sure doctor strange and you
know Rebecca uh Reggie McAdams like yeah
but I don't feel like a lot there's a
lot of that there's a lot of like paper
Tony we've seen we see them yeah in this
position where they can't be together
and that's the love is like they talk
about what it was when we didn't witness
it because and now we can't witness it
because of the circumstance and and it's
all like longing and wistful and and
sort of burdened by circumstances like I
don't even think of Tony and pepper as
kissing and like yeah right think of
them as I think of them as like
co-workers as like rude buds that are
always together isn't that weird yes it
is like when Tony died I was like I
can't imagine them kissing and like I do
think there is a it kind of scares me
about like that being our culture our
culture taking like a thing that is a
positive and getting rid of it is kind
of scary mm-hmm so uh that was one of
the big reasons I defended Eternal so
hard is I was like at least it's a step
and it had multiple types of
relationships and it had like I didn't
necessarily think there was a lot of
chemistry between those two leads but I
thought that was a ton of chemistry with
Angelina Jolie and Gilgamesh I thought
there was a ton of Chemistry Between
um uh Brian Tyree Henry's character and
his husband I thought like those and
your boy uh uh uh Barry Oh my God which
was on set and um and um yeah and drewga
Makari was because of the real life
chemistry like Barry kogan and that girl
I was like I'll watch these two these
guys and that's like so important so for
me eternals like I feel like Chloe shop
brought a lot of love to it and this
story I know it seems like I wanted to
change it because I did but this story
is one of those anchor points of love
for me in comics and and I love that for
it is it a very thick book like it's
there's a version you can read where
it's like a Year's worth but there's
also like you can go so like there are
two you know ways to go at it because
yeah is this like a a very paired down
version of what this is okay like this
story lasted a long time and was like a
bestseller and sold out and like you
know was was so impactful for you and
the next Arc is very impactful as well
but it's also very nice it's the next
Target so uh but yeah this was a great
with what they had they did what they
could yeah yeah I thought it was it's
one where I want to read Flashpoint but
after that movie I'm like man I feel
like I got the full meal and I know
there's more and I'm excited for that
more whereas this is like this was a
solid this is a good meal I like this
but I I'm like almost certain that
there's just way more to this story that
I like gotta seek out the book to like
really kind of you know when you eat a
really good dinner like a really good
dinner and then later you see it as a TV
dinner and you're like that is going to
be adequate with what's inside sure and
you accept that this would be good you
throw in the microwave and you're like
I'll get enough of that flavor to remind
my brain how much I like that other meal
this is the microwave dinner of death
Superman I can I can kind of I can kind
of feel that but I but I did like yeah I
liked the the fact that they rounded it
out and they gave a lot of breath and
time to Clark's struggle Lois's struggle
her talking to cat at the office I like
the Justice League a lot I didn't
realize it was Cat the first time they
introduced her because it was just so I
don't think they said her name it was
kind of a cat in the comics is like a
really strong character I think she's
Calista Flockhart in the Supergirl show
like she's a she's a fixture and I was
like oh oh that's who it is yeah yeah
but but you know just having Justice for
cat uh but yeah having those elements
having the Justice like I I liked all
the I think the personalities of all the
voice actors that they've compiled for
this Justice League are really strong
and even when they show up for little
appearances like this like I can
certainly see them all being much more
significant in the book sure but based
that was an element that's like okay
based off everything we've seen in these
movies up till now I like the
involvement of all these guys I want to
flash Green Lantern spin off all day
every day uh martial manager never gets
to speak I don't think Hawkman spoke
Hawkman he showed up though sure did
swing his name for a hot second there
the fight there was cool I loved the
last doomsday fight I just I wanted a
little bit more though and doomsday was
quite intense
Relentless and we and that next snap at
the end like you really feel that oomph
and and I I liked Alex in this I liked
his weird
who played him Rayne Wilson oh that's
right that's right yeah that was a great
weird choice not not Stephen Colbert but
yeah I loved his his whole life I'm
Gonna Save the damn but I didn't think
this through I guess I really want that
phone call Ryan Wilson's like yes I'll
play Lex Luthor like what like I love
someone I had that idea and everybody
was like No And then it worked yeah I'm
for it I'm with it uh so directors the
action was great because uh they had the
bandwidth sure yeah yeah I enjoyed it uh
and I hope I hope you folks do too if
you did enjoy it please read the comic
uh cause there's a lot more and I'm also
anyone in the know you're excited for
what John's about to experience because
the next Arc of this is gonna be a lot
of fun but before we get there we got
some Constantine goodness which I'm very
excited about uh these have been great
please do leave a comment please do hit
that like please do subscribe if you
want to watch it with all of our
be a hatred because we had a lot of
tense watching faces this go around uh
but yeah thank you so much for tuning
into these we really love doing them or
I I know I do and I know John says but I
want to speak for flying each time every
time boy these are Agony he's doing two
things one he's seen them all so he's
pretending that's right I've read all
these books read them all I've seen them
in all the movies and two he's
pretending to enjoy the experience so
all the lies the fakest nerd geez I'm
into this guy just like what's the
difference who's gonna be coming that's
that's the ultimate that would be my my
super villain comic is is fake nerd and
the way and and the context is that that
they've amassed all of the possible
knowledge and Care none and less than
none I actually on that exact note
before I leave uh I I have a fake nerd
apology retraction uh last week oh I
miss took a character for another
because of how similar they are ice and
Fries comic book jail those costumes so
similar and I thought the beauty of of
some of the the stuff in the comic which
I still recommend human target is genius
is that she has villainous elements so I
was like oh they just made a full-on
villain had villainous elements whereas
like it was just different character so
like Fire and Ice in the comic are
fantastic killer frost I do know I
thought they were like going by like a
nickname I thought like ice was like
because I didn't I don't know ice so I
thought it was the character I do know
and I thought because the costumes are
similar so apologies that's not a
mistake I would have made I mean because
you've just just saying so apologies
separating at home and uh and thank you
for telling me many times how wrong I
was I I do apologize all right that is
going to do it for this week's episode
we're gonna take a week off because I'm
traveling but when I'm back we're gonna
dive into the next thing again like
subscribe comment we will see you soon
reject Nation much love
and a very special shout out to Garth
McMurray he is a gentleman he is a
scholar he is lovely he also goes uh I
has a lovely relationship with a very
lovely comic store that I will be going
to as soon as possible yes on that East
Side uh and always always very uh
positive force in every Twitter thread
Discord it's any interneting I've had
with Garth McMurray has been positive
internet I can't say that about a lot of
interneting so much much appreciated to
you good sir we'll see you next time
thank you for being a patreon thank you
for being awesome
[Music]